[Music]
here's to the journey
the unforgettable adventures
the epic quests the decades
of discoveries
we found each other through a shared
passion for games
more than just a company a family
with an unwavering belief in people and
what we could make together
for the last 35 years we've grown
from a small basement in maryland
to studios and offices around the world
[Music]
together we brought our dreams to life
worlds that inspire creativity and
chaos worlds where players are free to
leave their own mark
[Music]
from snow-covered peaks to the fiery
depths of hell
to post-apocalyptic wastelands
and beyond
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Music]
thank you so much
[Music]
so here's to the games we've made and to
the games we'll make tomorrow
[Music]
here's to staying true to the vision
that inspired it all
a legacy built with love respect
and a dedication to excellence
and here's to you for being there with
us
through it all
a new chapter has begun
here's to the journey just getting
[Music]
started
you